Let's say that Arman
today is 18 years old.
And let's say that Diya
today is 2 years old.
And what I am curious
about in this video
is how many years will it
take-- and let me write this
down-- how many
years will it take
for Arman to be three
times as old as Diya?
So that's the
question right there,
and I encourage you to try to
take a shot at this yourself.
So let's think about
this a little bit.
We're asking how many
years will it take.
That's what we don't know.
That's what we're curious about.
How many years will
it take for Arman
to be three times
as old as Diya?
So let's set some variable--
let's say, y for years.
Let's say y is equal
to years it will take.
So given that, can we
now set up an equation,
given this information,
to figure out
how many years it will take
for Arman to be three times as
old as Diya?
Well, let's think about how
old Arman will be in y years.
How old will he be?
Let me write here.
In y years, Arman is
going to be how old?
Arman is going to be--
well, he's 18 right now--
and in y years, he's
going to be y years older.
So in y years, Arman is
going to be 18 plus y.
And what about Diya?
How old will she be in y years?
Well, she's 2 now,
and in y years,
she will just be 2 plus y.
So what we're curious about,
now that we know this,
is how many years will it
take for this quantity,
for this expression, to be
three times this quantity?
So we're really curious.
We want to solve for
y such that 18 plus y
is going to be equal
to 3 times 2 plus y.
Notice, this is
Arman in y years.
This is Diya in y years.
And we're saying that what
Arman's going to be in y years
is three times what Diya
is going to be in y years.
So we've set up our equation.
Now we can just solve it.
So let's take this step by step.
So the left hand
side-- and maybe I'll
do this in a new
color, just so I
don't have to keep switching--
so on the left hand side,
I still have 18 plus y.
And on the right hand side,
I can distribute this 3.
So 3 times 2 is 6.
3 times y is 3y.
6 plus 3y.
And then it's always nice
to get all of our constants
on one side of the equation,
all of our variables
on the other side
of the equation.
So we have a 3y over here.
We have more y's on the right
hand side than the left hand
side.
So let's get rid of the
y's on the left hand side.
You could do it
either way, but you'd
end up with negative numbers.
So let's subtract
a y from each side.
And we are left with, on
the left hand side, 18.
And on the right hand side
you have 6 plus 3 y's.
Take away one of those y's.
You're going to be
left with 2 y's.
Now we can get rid of
the constant term here.
So we will subtract
6 from both sides.
18 minus 6 is 12.
The whole reason why we
subtracted 6 from the right
was to get rid of this, 6
minus 6 is 0, so you have 12
is equal to 2y.
Two times the number of
years it will take is 12,
and you could probably
solve this in your head.
But if we just want a
one-coefficient year,
we would divide
by 2 on the right.
Whatever we do to one
side of an equation,
we have to do it
on the other side.
Otherwise, the equation will
not still be an equation.
So we're left with y is equal
to 6, or y is equal to 6.
So going back to the
question, how many years
will it take for Arman to be
three times as old as Diya?
Well, it's going
to take six years.
Now, I want you to verify this.
Think about it.
Is this actually true?
Well, in six years, how
old is Arman going to be?
He's going to be 18 plus 6.
We now know that
this thing is 6.
So in six years,
Arman is going to be
18 plus 6, which
is 24 years old.
How old is Diya going to be?
Well, she's going to be 2
plus 6, which is 8 years old.
And lo and behold, 24 is,
indeed, three times as old
as 8.
In 6 years-- Arman
is 24, Diya is
8-- Arman is three times as
old as Diya, and we are done.